professor Ryan Alford thank you so much
for joining me today my pleasure
professor Alford in the beginning of
this book you you spent a lot of time
talking about the rule of law why is
that important and how is it so
difficult to understand this concept
it's difficult to understand because
it's a principle that's so foundational
that we've taken it for granted even for
centuries the United States was the
first government explicitly founded on
that principle attempting to instantiate
the principle that the government should
be one of laws and not of men so out of
core really quite a simple principle the
idea that everyone should be subject to
the laws and in particular that the
president should be legally accountable
the problem of course is that it's very
difficult to instantiate and when it
relies on a certain level of goodwill
and expectation of the political process
will function correctly that those
expectations are not really ones we can
take for granted anymore in the 21st
century now you of course a practiced in
the United States both both in regional
and domestic and international affairs
why why a book about the United States
situation when there are so many other
situations including here in Canada that
might be of interest it's remarkable how
the United States has projected its
power across the world and it's
attempting to reshape international
norms in its own image right now the
United States is conducting hostile
interventions with its military in seven
different foreign nations we very rarely
speak about for instance the blockade of
Yemen or American special forces
operations in Somalia but they're going
on all the time and as they conduct
those operations they're attempting to
change international law to make what
they do retro actively legal and they're
saying in changing law they're changing
their own constitution or circumventing
it or what exactly they're trying to
develop doctrines that would allow the
President to do whatever he wants to do
with any kind of oversight from Congress
or the courts which is really quite
shocking what got me into this I was
involved in litigation along with the
ACLU and the Center for Constitutional
Rights where an American citizen
attempted to prevent the President of
the United States for murdering him via
drone strike and the court in the
District of Columbia said I simply can't
supervise this sort of question it's a
political question reserved to the
president so when someone is saying I
have a constitutional right not to be
killed and the courts say while I'm
sorry I can't adjudicate that because
the president has decided that it's the
appropriate course of action you have to
ask yourself how we cross some sort of
fundamental threshold where we're now
not even just in a problem of
constitutional crisis but really have we
crossed over the normative order into a
state of affairs that's no longer
characterized by the rule of law is this
a situation where the president in this
case for example is somehow above the
law because the law refuses to take a
look at it's the same sort of problem
that brought about the rule of law in
the first place so in a 17th century
English king saying well of course I'm
subject to the law in that case it would
be God's law but no one can judge
whether or not in compliance with the
law so the United States has situation
where President Trump he sometimes runs
into problems because he'll say
explicitly I'm above the law no one can
stop me the courts can't stop me and
then you have courts pushing back a
little bit you have Congress pushing
back a little bit but in practice all he
does is act as if he's above the law the
courts are quite willing to say well
we're not fit to judge him we're not fit
to judge his cut his conduct in foreign
affairs or in defense of national
security and Congress does the same so
we have a practical situation that
whenever he says well this is an
exception it relates to national
security
everyone just acts as if he's above the
law I'd like you to explain the title a
permanent state of emergency unchecked
executive power and the demise of the
rule of law the demise of the rule of
law is directly related to the creation
of a permanent state of emergency so
after the 9/11 attacks in 2001 there was
a sense in Washington that something had
to be done the president had to be given
all these extensive powers to really get
down to business
Dick Cheney once they misleading as
having to work on the dark side and they
gave him that power with the idea that
well this was a temporary crisis we
would deal with the terrorists who
committed 9/11 bombing and now 16 years
later we have a civil war in Syria where
there's an organization known as Lou
Walsh um which is funded by the United
States and given weapons but in the
United States despite the fact that is
in fact a Syrian branch of al Qaeda so
the categories have become so amorphous
the grant of power to the President to
pursue whichever people he believes
they're his enemies at the moment I've
just been stretched so far that it can
cover literally anyone and I describe
that in detail in the book groups like
organizations in Somalia and Yemen are
now being designated as the effective
equivalent of the people who brought
down the World Trade Center and that's
allowing for a permanent state of
warfare which people like James Madison
said would destabilize the American
President but having governments
throughout history modern history anyway
have given themselves
excess power in a state of emergency I
mean we had the we had the war Measures
Act for example in which the Canadian
government for example in the Second
World War
practically controlled everything and
you know that was a state of emergency
and I'm just wondering given the current
political situation worldwide where we
do have such incredible d-- stability i
mean if they're not in some way a
permanent state of emergency in a way
because i mean you have these lone wolf
attacks you never know where it's coming
from the problem is that rather than
declaring war on a set of combatants or
even a particular terrorist organization
we've declared a war on terror which is
kind of like declaring a war on drugs or
war on poverty terrors like the poor it
will always be with us if we give the
president the power to continue as long
as there's going to be some sort of
terrorist threat we're effectively
saying well we need to abandon
democratic governance it was a failed
experiment we have situations also for
example in the situation with with
turkey where the president has given
himself extraordinary power is there is
there a thought in your mind this idea
of leaders acquiring more and more power
something that is sort of spreading i
mean could it possibly happen in places
like Canada Britain South Africa
Australia anywhere else like that
I do think so I think that we should
absolutely avoid complacency it would
have been unthinkable in the United
States after the reconstruction of the
rule of law post watergate that this
would occur so quickly there is a
tremendous appetite in the public for
just someone who can get things done cut
through all the problems of governance
and that person who comes forward like a
strongman saying I can solve all the
nation's problems is tremendously
attractive the problem is that it
denigrates the political process to the
point where well you have to ask
yourself do we believe in democracy at
all right now actually a Supreme Court
justice was speaking at a conference at
the University of Montreal on Tuesday
and she gave us the statistic that one
in six Americans state openly that they
prefer that America be ruled by its
military and that's really quite
shocking for a state founded on the
principle that it should be a government
of laws and not of them but in in the
case where there is a an emergency of
some kind isn't it true that which you
have a strong central power that they
can get things done because you can't
deal with an emergency with a committee
for example there's just too much
conflict of ideas and so on
certainly I guess the question is
whether or not the state of emergency is
going to exist within the laws or
whether on it exists outside of the laws
so if you have a situation right now for
instance Canada has the Emergencies Act
there are place two more measures act
Parliament can say well we really think
that this emergency is over but if you
hand over all the power to continued the
emergency to one person the most
powerful person in the political system
who gains nothing by declaring that
emergency over and gains everything by
continuing it it's going to be continued
indefinitely whether or not the
particular conditions continue to exist
and then you have something like I would
say perónist Argentina where you do in
fact crush the opposition but you're
just so enamored with power that the
state of emergency continues
indefinitely professor Ron Alfred in one
of the cases you mentioned as an example
is where pre-emptive action is taken and
again you know I don't know how many
people would disagree with the idea that
let's take out this organization or that
person before because we know they will
at some point before they harm our
people or our country well when you say
that we know usually that's we allege or
some fashion the government or the
intelligence services alleges you can
comb through the records of see system
and before at the RCMP National Security
Service and find all kinds of
organizations activists in favor of
social housing the caravan Against
Torture is a prominent example I don't
know more another example being labeled
terrorists so I really have a problem
with that being done in secret and being
done outside of the protections of the
legal order I think the relevant
question for the government is why are
the tools of law nor not sufficient to
this problem why couldn't we say well
let's treat this like any other criminal
problem rather than effectively
declaring war on these organizations and
giving them the status of military
fighters we
has been tremendously helpful for them
Osama bin Laden before he committed the
9/11 attacks stated that his goal was to
draw the United States into a military
confrontation with al-qaeda that would
elevate their status in the Middle East
to the status of the opposition to the
United States treating them like a
military force treating them as if they
deserve to be the object of declaration
of war is giving them a status that they
don't deserve but unfortunately it's a
dynamic that serves both them and the
governments that pursue them is that the
same case with daesh
well we have to ask ourselves who has
funded - there are really really
problematic links between various
security services and - I think that the
Kenyan government should be asking
itself
who is most effectively fighting - and
why would we align ourselves with
organizations that are fighting that
effective opposition to - you can't have
your cake and eat it too if you're going
to say that the Syrian government should
be funded by organizations very close to
al-qaeda at the same time that the
Syrian government is the only effective
opposition to - I really have a hard
time taking seriously the proposition
that either the American or the Canadian
governments think that - is a serious
problem
professor Alford what do you want people
to understand from this book permanent
state of emergency unchecked executive
power and demise the rule of law the
bottom line message is that we can never
be complacent about our constitutional
order if we believe that legality and
the accountability of government is
something we're preserving we have to
fight for it and when we see the
government saying the courts have no
role here you shouldn't be able to bring
a lawsuit challenge in its conduct any
inquiry into her conduct should be
secret and kept out of the public eye
the immediate question should be why we
demand the government justify that to us
we are the people they are the
government in the state of emergency the
government says we deserve all the power
because we can keep you safe question
that premise if you believe that the
constitutional order is worth protecting
professor Ryan Alfred thank you very
much for this thank you